foreign
diagnosis is cptsd anxiety or to autism
and ADHD with clinical depression
processing deficit to me mental health
is a state of well-being and it's
something that affects at least my
everyday life it's not just about
getting a diagnosis but how can I live
healthily mentally and physically in my
daily life it's an invisible Garden that
you don't really realize how many weeds
are lying in there until like you're
forced to look at it be it through like
a panic attack or like an episode of
some sort the covet pandemic impacted my
mental health by making me feel extra
isolated I definitely felt like I had
support but maybe not in the ways that I
would have wanted and that something
that I wasn't very vocal about either
though no one wants to think that they
have something wrong with them or it
wants to commit to improving the self on
a daily basis it's not really taught my
family members who are definitely in
India culturally I see many differences
between how we address mental health how
we address gender class issues ETC et
cetera so it makes sense that they would
see this in a different light when I
open up I create space for other people
to open up and now we can really get to
like the gritty aspects of it once the
shame is then we can like find
Solutions or come to each other in like
moments of distress and be able to work
through it having a psychiatrist and
therapist is cool but like having a
sense of community be it for some people
it's church for some people it's a
12-step meeting it really takes the way
of like the loneliness of like feeling
broken off your shoulders talking and
communicating about it is super
important that way you can start
discovering ways that could be
beneficial to you I think it's also a
process of trial and error it's such a
big
it's a huge issue that you know I'm
really happy we're discussing
[Music]